you definitely remember snaps spectacles
not only was it the company's first
attempt at making hardware but they were
ridiculously hard to get your hands on
which in retrospect was a brilliant
marketing stunt for a pair of toy like
sunglasses that cost 130 dollars and
only captured ten seconds video but to a
lot of people surprise snap is still
making hardware in fact the company says
it's really committed to it and at some
point in the next decade it thinks that
all of its hardware is going to converge
with all of its software and we're all
just gonna be wearing camera on our
faces which is why today we're looking
at snaps second version of spectacles at
its core it's another camera on your
face but snapchat has added some
features that are supposed to nudge this
whole idea a little closer to normalcy
so my wired colleague Arielle and I
decided to compare version 1 with
version 2 and we figured what better
place to do it at than a giant amusement
park like Great America because we have
really tough jobs and you love roller
coasters right yeah I hate roller
coasters
this new pair of spectacles looks a lot
like the old pair with the exception of
some new colors but there are subtle
aesthetic changes the first thing you'll
notice is that these are less clunky
they're a little less nerd alert and
more I just came from Coachella that's
especially true on the sides here where
you can see that they're thinner the new
pair also doesn't have yellow rings
around the lenses snap figured that the
LED lights are enough of an indicator
that you are recording something the
more important stuff is what's under the
hood or frame the new specs have an
improved image processor and improved
Wi-Fi chip and the glasses now transfer
HD footage to your phone by default
whatever the equivalent of HD is and
snaps circular format also you can now
take still images with these to take a
picture you press and hold the capture
button video capture function is still
the same you press the button and you
let go the good news is snap says a
firmware update will let you take spill
images with the old pair 2 which means
Arielle can do this with her specs -
another feature update is that these
spectacles are water resistant that
doesn't mean that you're gonna want to
go deep-sea diving or anything like that
wearing them but you can wear them
around the pool get some water splashed
on yourself and they should be fine or
you can do something like this
snap says you should get the same
battery life with D spectacles that you
did in the first pair but the battery in
the new ones is smaller and they're also
qualifying it differently which is a
little confusing they used to say you
could get 100 snaps in a single charge
and now they're saying you can take and
transfer 70 snaps on a single charge
these also cost more there are one
hundred and fifty dollars and finally
you can order prescription spectacles
too through the website lens of all so
all of these updates they're totally
fine it's like snapchat went down a list
of features that people complained about
with the first version and decided to
fix them but it's not a dramatically
different product still which kind of
begs the question what is snapchat doing
and I think what they're doing is
they're just trying to get people a
little more comfortable with the idea of
wearing a camera on your face I mean
they see people love their GoPros and
they see that people have their
smartphones with them all the time but
in their pockets and so they're kind of
going for something in between with us
right if you didn't love the first
version you're probably not gonna go out
and buy the second version but it's less
about snapchats bid to get you buying
this product and more about the long
game to get people comfortable with
wearing cameras on their faces yeah and
to some extent things like HD video or
water resistance probably helped make
that case a little bit one thing that
still bugs me about these is that when
you share the video outside of a
snapchat app it is still that
proprietary circular format I kind of
wish that they would just let you export
it as flat 2d video I think that would
make it more accessible to people in
general not just early adopters or nerds
like us but it's a good reminder that if
you buy into spectacles you are still
buying into snapchats world and the
snapchat app I mean however fleeting
that may be hey you want to go on that
roller coaster again I I think I'm good
I'm good
you